once again in the u.s a white police
officer fatally shoots another unarmed
black man this is a very regrettable
very sad day in our community and we
have
heard
several expressions of
a range of emotions
and we will get through this grand
rapids police has released the
controversial video of the confrontation
on wednesday a police dashboard camera
captured an unarmed officer pulling over
patrick leoya a 26 year old immigrant
from the democratic republic of the
congo hey stay in the car
stay in the car
leo seems to ignore that order the
officer's body camera picks up the
struggle
the plate doesn't belong in this car
as the officer tries to arrest him he
runs
then a scuffle the officer climbs on
leo's back struggling to handcuff him
[Music]
then the officer's camera is turned off
either deliberately or because the off
button was pressed during the struggle a
home security camera and leo's passenger
videotaped the rest
the taser goes off
twice
missing leoya and hitting the ground
then
the shot
it's unclear why at that point the
officer fired civil rights attorney ben
crump says the video shows it was an
unnecessary excessive and fatal use of
force against an unarmed black man who
was confused and terrified for his life
local police have turned over the
investigation to michigan state police
the grand rapids police chief has left
open the possibility that the struggle
over the taser had the officer in fear
for his life they were struggling over
the taser from my view
of the video so this is not a conclusion
because i don't know what other what
other information is out there but it
looks like that they were struggling
over the taser for about 90 seconds
police killings of black americans in
recent years particularly the videotaped
death of george floyd in minneapolis
launched the black lives matter movement
in protests across the u.s
[Music]
whatever conclusion the investigation
finds in this case leoya's family and
civil rights activists are left to mourn
yet another police killing of an unarmed
black american john hendren al jazeera